this week's first Democratic debates in
the twenty20 presidential campaign are
likely to focus heavily on race and
civil rights one candidate mayor Pete
Budaj
was emotional as he heard from angry
constituents yesterday in his home city
of South Bend Indiana a police involved
shooting that killed the black man has
raised racial tensions there Nancy
Cordes is covering the 20/20 campaign
Nancy how far how is the mayor
responding to the outrage and the
criticism there in his home town good
morning well he's taking responsibility
for a controversial body camera policy
there and for the shrinking diversity in
his city's police department and he
acknowledged the racial tensions that
have dogged the police department
throughout his seven-year tenure as
mayor we have tried but not succeeded to
increase diversity in the police
department and we need help at home in
South Bend Indiana
Budda judge was confronted by
accusations of bias in his city's police
force when he sees the police he is
afraid that is not what's supposed to
happen racial tensions flared last week
after a white South Bend police officer
shot and killed a black man who was
allegedly holding a knife the officer
was wearing a body camera but it was not
turned on if anyone who is on patrol is
shown to be a racist or to do something
racist
[Applause]
in a way that is substantiative that is
their last day on the street who to
judge dropped off the campaign trail
after the shooting last week I just
think it's my job I don't know if it's
smart or not I don't know if it's
strategic or not but it's my city not a
racist bone in my body race has been a
central issue on the trail two Democrats
are still chewing over a former Vice
President Joe Biden's boast last week
that he found ways in Congress to
compromise with segregationist senators
even if he disagreed with him praising
and coddling individuals who made it
their life works and built their
reputation of segregation of the races
in the United States that's a problem
despite his time off the trail Buddha
judge says he still plans to take part
in the debate later this week there are
some 2020 contenders who did not qualify
for the debates this time around and
former Pennsylvania Democratic
congressman Joe Sestak just announced
he's joining the race bringing the total
number of Democratic hopefuls Anthony -
25 25 that's a nice nice solid number
Bernie Sanders will unveil a plan today
to cancel 1.6 trillion dollars of
student debt Nancy how exactly is that
going to work well that one-point-six
accounts for all of the student debt in
the United States Sanders will propose
that it gets paid through new taxes on
Wall Street that will reportedly raise
more than two trillion dollars over ten
years it's a similar plan of that's come
from another progressive senator and
2020 contender Elizabeth Warren who
proposed eliminating debt for some but
not all students and all of this comes
ahead of this first democratic debate
but with so many candidates on the stage
it's not clear if this hot topic is even
going to come up anything 25 candidates
Wow Nancy thank you